okay well in which case let's crack on
so uh ladies and gentlemen get ready to
meet the cunning Maverick of Silicon
Valley the one and only George hotz
renowned for his daring exploits Hots
commands in enigmatic Persona which
merges the technical finesse of Elon
Musk and the wit of Tony Stark and the
charm of a True Tech Outlaw now many of
you would have or indeed should have
seen this man on Lex's podcast recently
for the third time no less from
crafterley jailbreaking the supposedly
Invincible iPhone to outsmarting the
mighty PlayStation 3 he's proven that no
Tech Fortress Is impregnable once
targeted for his audacious creativity by
Sony with a lawsuit this hacker wizard
stoically dance past the curveballs
thrown by the tech Giants all achieved
with the graceful swag of a street smart
Prodigy now when he's not out foxing
major corporations you'll find him at
the heart of the Avant guard of AI
technology gallantly trailblazing
through the Wilds of the tech Frontier
he's currently building a startup called
micrograd which is building super fast
AI running on Modern Hardware and truly
he's the James Bond of Silicon Valley
minus the martinis of course now uh
please welcome the unparalleled code
Cowboy the Unapologetic technomancer
George hotz whoo
anyway also joining us for the big fight
this evening is the steadfast Sentinel
of AI safety Connolly he undeterred by
the sheer complexity of artificial
intelligence Conor Braves the cryptic
operations of text generating models
with Steely resolve now about two years
ago Connor took on the Herculean task of
safeguarding humanity from a potential
AI apocalypse his spirit is Relentless
his intellect razor sharp and his will
to protect is unwavering now drawing on
his contentious claim that we are super
super [__]
uh
yeah uh Connor channels the urgency of
our predicament into his work now his
startup conjecture isn't just a
glorified Tech Endeavor but it's a
Lifeboat for us all racing against the
Breakneck speed of AI advancement with
the fates of Nations possibly at stake
he's determined to break the damning
prophecy and render us super super saved
so um brace for a showdown as kanalihi
the Maverick defender of ai's boundaries
strides into the ring now the man who
declared we're super super [__] is
here to prove just how super super not
[__] we could be if we make the right
decisions today so please give it up for
Mr Connor super super Leahy woo
now um Connor I'd appreciate it if you
don't go down in the fourth I want this
fight to go the distance now we're
running for 90 minutes this evening
there'll be a 10 minute openers from uh
from uh we said Hots didn't we from from
Hots first and then Connor and uh I'll
only step into the ring if the punch-up
gets too out of hand and unfortunately
we won't be taking live questions today
because we want to maximize the Carnage
on the battlefield George hotz your
opening statements please
um yeah we're super super [__] I think
I agree with you
well that was a short fight yeah look I
think okay
um so to to make my opening statement
clear and why maybe it doesn't make that
much sense for me to go first I think
that the trajectory of all of this
was somewhat inevitable right
so you have uh humans over time and you
can look at a 1980 human and a 2020
human they look pretty similar right
Ronald Reagan Joe Biden and that's all
to say
um whereas a 1980 computer is like an
apple II and a 2020 computer is a is a
M1 Max MacBook like
lines looking like this right so you
have one line like this one line like
this these lines eventually cross and I
don't see any reason that Line's gonna
stop right I've seen a few of the other
guests argue something like well llms
can't Problem Solver but it doesn't
matter like
if this one can't the next one will
whatever you call I don't believe that
there's a step function I don't believe
that like oh now it's conscious so now
it's intelligent I think it's all on a
gradient
um and I think this gradient will
continue to go up
will approach human level and
pass human level
now this belief that we are uniquely
[__] because of this
the amount of power in the world is
about to increase right when you think
about power and you think about shut up
you can just talk about energy usage the
amount of energy usage in the world is
going to go up right the amount of
intelligence in the world is going to go
up
we may be able to do some things to slow
it down or speed it up based on
political decisions but it doesn't
matter the trajectory is up or major
catastrophe right the only way it goes
down is through War nuclear Annihilation
bio Annihilation meteor impact some kind
of major annihilation
what we can control and what I think is
super important we control is what the
distribution of that new power looks
like
um
I am not afraid of super intelligence I
am not afraid to live in a world among
super intelligences I am afraid if a
single person or a small group of people
has a super intelligence and I do not
and this is where we get to check in
that a chicken man is the man who owns
the chicken farm
uh there's many chickens in the chicken
farm and there is one chicken pan it is
unquestionable that chicken man rules
and if you believe Chicken Man rules
because of his size uh I uh invite you
to look at cow man who also rules the
cows and the cows are much larger than
him Chicken Man rules because of his
intelligence this is basic less wrong
stuff everyone kind of knows this how'd
the squishy things take over the world
look I agree with Elio's yutkowski all
up to Nuke the data centers right
um so uh I do not want to be a chicken
uh and if people decide they are going
to restrict open source AI or make sure
I can't get access to the compute and
only trusted people like chicken man get
access to the compute well [__] man I'm
the chicken and uh yeah I don't want to
be the chicken uh so I think that's my
are we [__] maybe
um I agree that that intelligence is
very dangerous how can you look at
intelligence and not say it's very
dangerous right intelligence is somehow
safe but
things like nuclear bombs are an
extremely false equivalency
because what does a nuclear bomb do
besides blow up and kill people
intelligence has the potential to make
us live forever intelligence has the
potential to let us colonize the Galaxy
intelligence has the potential to
meet God
nuclear bombs do not they just blow up
um so I think the question and like you
have things like crypto which are a
clear advantage to the defender at least
today and you have things like nuclear
bombs which are a clear advantage to the
attacker AI it's unclear I think the
best defense against an AI trying to
manipulate me and that's what I'm really
worried about future psyops you know
we're already seeing it today with the
voice changer stuff like you're never
going to know who's human the world's
about to get crazy
um the best defense I could possibly
have is an AI in my room being like
don't worry I got you it's you and me
we're on a team we're aligned
I'm not worried about alignment as a
technical challenge I'm worried about
alignment as a political challenge
Google doesn't like me open AI doesn't
like me but me and my computer
you know we like each other we're
aligned and we're standing against the
world that has always since the
beginning of History maximally been
trying to screw you over right
intelligence people think that one super
intelligence is going to come and be
unaligned against humanity all of
humanity is all aligned against each
other
I mean we have some common values but
really come on everyone's trying to scam
everybody the only reason you really
team up with someone else is like hey
man what if we team up and scam them
right hey what if we team up call
ourselves America and we we uh we built
a big army and say we're free and
independent yeah right it's that Force
that has made Humanity cooperate
Humanity by default is very unaligned
and has every kind of belief Under the
Sun so I'm not worried about AI showing
up with a new belief Under the Sun I'm
not worried about the amount of
intelligence increasing I'm worried
about a few entities that are unaligned
with me acquiring god-like powers and
using them to exploit me
that's my opening statement
cool yeah thanks that's uh that's I mean
yeah I also kind of agree with you and
most of the things you say it's a few
details I'd like to dig into there but
for most of the things you say I do
think I agree with you here I think it's
absolutely let me just like start with
saying I totally agree with you that
misuse and like you know Bad actors were
using AGI is a horrible dangerous
outcome that's that's like you know
sometimes the the uh less wrong you know
crowd likes to talk about X risk but
also sometimes I've talked about s risk
suffering risks so things are worse than
death I believe that you can probably
almost only get S risks from misuse I
don't think you can get S risks probably
like you you can but it's extremely
unlikely to get it from like just like
raw misalignments like you'd have to
like get extraordinarily unlucky so
while I do it so I do think for example
a very you know controllable AGI or
super intelligence in the hand of
sadistic psychopath is significantly in
a sense worse than a paperclip maximizer
so I think this is something we would
agree on probably sure so I I think I'm
I think I'm pretty much I'm bored with
you on a lot of things there where I
think thing things come about a bit of
the tale as I think there's two points
where I would like to take as my opening
statement two things one I want to talk
about
the first one is I want to talk about
the technical problem of alignment so am
I concerned about the kinds of things
like misuse and like small groups of
people centralizing power potentially
foreign yeah I I think this is a very
very significant problem that I do think
about a lot and that'll be the second
thing I want to talk about the first
thing I want to talk about is that I
don't even think we're going to make it
to that point I don't think we're going
to get to the point where anyone as a
super intelligence that's helping them
out we're good if we don't solve very
hard technical problems which are
currently not on track to being solved
by default you don't get a bunch of you
know super intelligence and boxes
working with a bunch of humans you get a
bunch of super intelligence you know
fighting each other working with each
other and just ignoring humans humans
just get cut out entirely from the
process and even then you know Pro it's
you know whether one takes over or they
find nicolibia I don't know like you
know who knows what happens now
but by default I wouldn't expect humans
to be part of the equilibrium anymore
once you're once you're the chicken man
well why do you need chickens you know
if you know maybe if they provide some
resource for you the reason humans have
chickens is that they make chicken
breasts I mean personally I wouldn't
like to be harvested for chicken breasts
just my personal opinion I consider this
a pretty bad outcome
um but even then well as a chicken man
finds a better way of chicken breasts or
you know modifies himself to no longer
need food I expect the chickens are not
going to be around for much longer you
know once we stop using horses for
transmutation didn't go very well for
the horses so that's kind of the first
part of my my point that I'd like to you
know maybe hear your opinions on hear
your thoughts on is that I think
the technical problem control is
actually very hard and and I think it's
unsolvable by any means I think like you
know you know you and like you know a
bunch of other smart people work on this
for like 10 years I think you can solve
it but it's not easy and it has to
actually happen and there is a deadline
for this
the second point I want to bring up is
kind of where you talk about how humans
are unaligned I think this is partially
definitely true I think I'm unusually I
am the more optimistic of the two of us
in this scenario not not as not a role I
often have in these discussions where I
actually think the amount of
coordination that exists between
Humanity especially in the modern world
is actually astounding
every single time two adult human males
meet and don't kill each other is a
miracle have you seen what happens when
two adult male chimps from two different
War bands meet each other it doesn't go
very well and those are already pretty
well coordinated animals because they
can have warbands what happens when you
know two male bugs or you know I don't
know sea slugs meet each other you know
either they ignore each other or you
know things go very poorly this is the
default outcome the true underlined
outcome the true default state of nature
is you can't have two adult males in the
same room at any time
I I saw this funny video on on Twitter
the other day where it was like you know
some Parliament I think in east Europe
or something and there's this big guy
and she's like going at this politician
who's like in his face he's like
screaming he was like going everywhere
and not a single punch will throw him no
did no one took on a knife no one took
out a gun and I was like and I was like
wow the fact that we're so civilized and
we're so aligned to each other that we
can have something this barbaric happen
and no one throws a punch is actually
shocking this is very unusual even for
humans if you go back 200 years
punches and probably gunshots would have
flown so this is not to say that humans
have some inherent special Essence that
we're good that we have solved goodness
or by any means what I'm saying is the
way I like to think about it is that
coordination is technology is a
technology you can improve upon it is
you can develop new methods of
coordination you can develop new
structures new institutions new systems
and I think it's very tempting for us
living in this modern world to it's kind
of like a fish and water effect we
forget how much of our life you know a
lot of our life is built on you know
atoms on you know physical technology a
lot of it's built on digital technology
but a lot of it is on social technology
and
it when I look at how you know how does
the world go well like you know should
it be only the you know special Elites
get control of the AI I'm like well
that's not really how I think about it I
think about it way more is what is a
coordination mechanism where we can
create a coordination selling point or
we can create a group an institution a
system of some kind that where people
will you know have game theoretic
incentives to cooperate on the system
the results in something that is net
positive for everyone because the truth
is is that positive some games do exist
and they're actually very profitable and
they're very good and I think if we can
turn you know you can turn any positive
sum game to an into a zero or a negative
something pretty easily it's much easier
to destroy than is to create but I think
it's absolutely possible to create
coordination technology around Ai and to
build coordination mechanisms that are
not positive for everyone involved
so those would be like my two points
happy to dig into any ones you you think
would be it'll lead to an interesting
Direction sure uh so I'll start with two
and then go to one uh so two uh I moved
to Berkeley in 2014 and I threw myself
the Mary cult uh I showed up at the Mary
office and I'm like hi I'm here to join
your cult uh it's a true story and
what I started to realize was
Miri
and less wrong in general have a very
poor grip on the practicalities of
politics very much I think there was
sort of a split uh you know uh uh Curtis
yarvin like new reaction this is a
spin-off of rationality and it's a
spin-off rationality that understood the
truth about human nature
so when I give you that you give that
example of two chimps meeting in the
woods and they're gonna fight
if I'm one of those chimps at least I
stand a chance right he might beat my
ass I might beat his but if I come up
against the FBI
things do not look good for me in fact
things so much do not look good for me
there's no way I'm gonna beat the FBI
the modern forces are so powerful
that this is not a oh we've established
a nice Cooperative shelling point this
is a we have pounded so much fear into
these people that they would never even
think of throwing a puncher firing a gun
we have made everybody terrified
and this isn't good we didn't we didn't
achieve this through some enlightened
cooperation we achieved this through a
massive propaganda effort right it's the
joke about you know the American Soldier
goes over to Russia and it's like uh man
you guys got some real propaganda here
and that the Russian soldiers like yeah
no I know it's bad but it's not as bad
as yours and the American Soldier is
like what propaganda
and the Russian just laughs right so so
this this didn't occur because of um
this occurred because of a absolute
tyrannical Force decided to dominate
everybody right
um now oh I think so uh I think there's
a way out of this I think there actually
is a way out of this right and I wrote a
blog post about this called individual
sovereignty and I think a really nice
world would be if all the stuff to live
food water Health Care electricity We're
generatable Off the Grid in a way that
you are individually Sovereign and this
comes back to my point about offense and
defense right if I have a world where
you don't want it to be extreme defense
you don't want every person to be able
to completely insulate them but you want
like okay it takes a whole bunch of
other people to gang up to take that guy
out right like that's that's a good
that's a good balance
um and the balance that we live in today
is there is one pretty much a unipolar
world I mean thank God for China but um
you know there's one there's one
unipolar world we've got the America and
what are you gonna run I'll pay taxes I
don't care if you've overseas right
um so yeah my point about the
coordination is that if you're okay with
solving coordination Problems by using a
single a Singleton super intelligent AI
to to to make everybody cower in fear
and tyrannize the future sure you'll get
coordination yeah that works that works
I'm the only guy with a gun and I got
10. I gotta name it all 10 of you and
you can all die or listen to me your
choice so I'm I'm curious about uh so I
understand what you're saying and I
think you make some decent points but um
I think I view the world a bit
differently from you and I'd like to
like dig into that a little bit so like
who do you think is less afraid someone
living just a median person living in
the United States of America or the
median person living in Somalia
sure America that's a fair
well that's kind of strange Somalia
doesn't have a government they have much
less tyranny you're much more you can
just buy a rocket launch rooms as I live
in a farm and just like you know kill
your neighbors and No One's Gonna Stop
you so like how does that interact with
your whole team those who will trade
liberty for safety deserve neither
that sorry I don't understand could you
elaborate a bit more
um in Somalia you have a chance in
America you do not right I am okay I
would rather live in fear I would rather
be worried about someone shooting a
rocket launcher at me than to have an
absolutely tyrannical government
just you know
just just like like a managerial class
I'm not saying by the way I agree with
you that these things are possible I
agree with you that the less wrong
notion of politics is possible I would
love to live in these sort of Worlds but
we don't
the the the Practical reality of
politics is so much more brutal and it
just comes from a straight up
instinct to dominate not an instinct uh
you know government by the people for
the people it's branding yeah I mean
yeah so to be clear I very much do not
agree with les Ron's views in politics
and a bit of an outcast for how I view
how conflict theory I view politics but
this is I feel like you're kind of
dodging the question here just a little
bit it's like well if that's true why
aren't you living in Somalia
I know people who've done it right it's
very hard it's very hard psychologically
okay so like tigers love Chum it turns
out right a tiger does not want to chase
down an antelope right a tiger would
love to just sit in the zoo and eat the
Chong right and like it takes a very
strong tiger to reject that and I'm not
that strong I hope there's people out
there who are I hope there's people out
there who are actually like you know I'm
just not I'm a weak little [__]
that's why I don't even desire right
okay I mean that's a fair answer but I
am a bit confused here so you're saying
that living in Somalia would be better
by some Metric but you're also saying
you prefer not living in Somalia so I
I'm a bit confused because like from my
perspective I want to live in a country
I want to live in and that's the one
which I think is better if I thought
another country was better then I would
just move there but personally that's
the tiger and the chum I think is a good
analogy right like if you have a choice
as a tiger you can live in a zoo and you
get a nice sized pen you know the
zookeepers are not abusive at all you
get fed this beautiful chopped up food
it's super easy you sit there get fat
lays around all day
or you can go to the wilds and in the
wild you're gonna have to hunt you might
not succeed at hunting it is just a you
know it's a brutal existence as a tiger
which one do you choose now you say oh
well obviously you know you're going to
choose the chum one yeah but do you see
what you're giving up
could you elaborate a little bit on what
I'm giving up you are giving up on the
nature of tiger
you you are effectively okay
um maybe I'll take this to an extreme
right
in the absolute extreme the country that
you would most rather live in is the one
that basically wireheads you right the
one and you can say that okay well I
don't want to be wireheaded but you know
there's a there's a gradient that'll get
you there Gandhi in the pill uh you know
um
well if you can live in this country you
can be happy feel safe and secure all
the time don't worry exactly about how
we're doing it you know
but right I mean it takes a very strong
person to it's going to take a very
strong person to say no to wireheading
so now I understand oh sorry I give I'll
give One More instrumental reason for
Living in America versus living in
Somalia
I thought that America and Somalia were
both like steady States I might choose
Somalia I don't think that I think that
being here I have a much better way of
escaping this of escaping the constant
tyranny that we're in and I think a
major way to do it is AI
I think that AI is is if I really if I
had an AGI if I had an AGI in my closet
right now I'll tell you what I'd do with
it I would have it build me a spaceship
that could get me off of this planet and
get out of here as close to the speed of
light as I possibly could and put a big
Shield up behind me blocking all
communication that's what I would do if
I had an AGI and I think that's
you know the right move and I have a lot
better chance of building that spaceship
right here than I do in Somalia right so
I'll give an instrument yeah if that's
okay that's a good instrumental well I I
will miss you if you leave though
that'll be a real shame it'll be
everyone should do it like this is this
is the move right and like let Humanity
I think look I agree with you though
we're gonna probably blow ourselves up
right but I think that the path
potentially through this
probably looks different from the path
you're imagining
I think that the reasonable position I'm
sorry
oh no no
um I think yeah maybe we're done with
this point I can come back I have a
response to your first time I would like
to if you don't mind just like full on
one one string there as well so one new
thing you said is like what will a tiger
choose and so my personal view of this
kind of thing and I think I want to
think about coordination is I think of
things so you put a lot of view on this
like fear-based domination and so on I'm
not going to deny that this isn't a
thing that happens I'm German you know
like you know I have living relatives
who can tell you some stories like I
understand like I I understand I'm not
I'm not denying these things by any
means
um
what I'm saying though is okay let's say
it was a bunch of tigers you know you
and me and all the other tigers and some
of the tigers are like man [__] this
whole like nature [__] is like really
not working for me how about we go build
a zoo together who's in
and then
other people like yeah you know what
actually that sounds awesome let's do
that
do you think that's okay like you think
that would be like a fair option for
them to do
sure but that's not where zoos come from
I I know I know I'm getting there I'm
getting there so like that is not where
Zeus come from sure but the
this analogy here is of course is that
this is
where a lot of human civilization comes
not all of it I understand that why
France was doing well in the first world
war was not because of democracy being
nice it was because democracy raises
large armies
it's um I'm very well aware of the real
politic as the Germans would say about
these kinds of factors and I and I fully
agree with you that a lot of the good
things that we have are
Not By Design so to speak you know
they're Cappy side effects you know
capitalism is a
credit assignment mechanism you know the
fact that also results in us having cool
video games and air conditioning it's
not an inherent feature of the system
it's it it's an execution mechanism and
so
totally Grant all of this I'm not saying
that every coordination thing is good
I'm not saying that you know there
aren't trade-offs especially you're
talking about I think Aesthetics
trade-offs you're like there's an
aesthetic that the tiger loses sure and
well I think personally Aesthetics are
subjective so I think this is something
that different people so the way I think
about Aesthetics is I think Aesthetics
are things you trade on is you know you
might want tigers in the wild to exist
okay fair enough that's a thing you can
want you know someone else might want
you know certain kind of art to exist
they might want
um a certain kind of religion to be
practiced or whatever these are
aesthetic preferences upon reality which
I think are very fair so the way I
personally think about this morally is
I'm like okay cool how can we maximize
Trade Surplus so you can spend your
resources on the Aesthetics you have you
want and I'll spend my resources on the
uh you know things I want
now maybe
the thing you described where everyone
just atomizes into their own systems
with their own value system with their
own Aesthetics completely separate
father is the best outcome awesome I
think this is
um have you heard the unibomber
manifesto I have not you should
um the problem with this everyone trades
on their own Aesthetics is you will
never be able to actually buy any
Aesthetics that are in conflict with the
system right the
you won't the system won't let you
okay uh by by that logic why do people
have free time
why don't they work all the time why
doesn't capitalism extract literally
every minute of them what do you think
that is
I think it's because it turns out that
we don't actually live in a capitalist
Society I think China is a lot closer to
a capitalist Society than America I
think America is kind of communist and I
think in a communist Society of course
you're going to get free time it turns
out that subsidizing all the homeless
people is a great idea right if you want
to keep power again do some absolute
tyrannical mechanism you do it right so
why do we have free time well you think
it's some victory of capitalism I think
it's because we do not live in a
capitalist country I think China's more
capitalist than America I think it's
because we trade on our Aesthetics I
think that different people have
different things to contribute to
various systems and not necessarily
capitalist or communist thing I'm saying
it's it's more energy is that in the in
the primordial environment if you have
to fight literally every single second
it's been every Jewel of energy you have
to scrounge together another Jewel of
energy you can't have free time it's not
about capitalism this is about entropy
this is about these kind of things we
have energy excess we have we've
produced systems that allow us to
extract more energy for Jewel we put in
and we can spend that extra energy on
things such as free time and the
distribution of you know Energy power
coordination whatever you want to call
it is another question would you agree
or disagree with this I mean I am taking
an extreme position when I say that
there are definitely positive sum
coordination problems that are solved by
governments right it is not all zero sub
or negative sum right I'm not I'm not
denying this but what I'm saying is
it's like I don't know man like the
existence of free time well that's all
great when you think you live in this
Surplus energy world right and maybe we
do right now but if some other country
took this seriously like China
who's going to win it a war who's gonna
win is it going to be the Chinese you
ever see the Chinese build a building
they got like 400 people there and
they're all there 24 hours a day and
they're getting the building built you
ever see Americans build a building it's
six guys two of them were working two of
them are shift supervisors and two of
them are on lunch breaks
oh you got your free time you got your
aesthetic preferences you know you
deserve to lose in a war right this
country deserves to lose in a war if
they keep acting the way they're acting
so I I definitely see the point you're
making and this is personally not a
thing I want to defend to for because
I'm not a military expert but I will
know I will note that the U.S has like
37 aircraft carriers and the Chinese
have like two and Americans are like
somehow you know despite being so lazy
and oh no they have all this you know
all this free time or whatever somehow
they're still military hegemen or
whatever and like their their biggest
rival Russia fighting this backwards
Water Country in Ukraine suddenly fold
and lose like three quarters of the
military it's what I'm saying is if you
have massive hegemony if you have truly
uh obnoxious Victory the way it should
look is if you laze around all the time
and you look like a [__] idiot and
you still win
yes and I'm not talking about Russia
Russia has a GDP the size of Italy this
is China here you might say that China
has two aircraft carriers the US has 37.
why do we have aircraft carriers who has
more drone building capacity the Chinese
or the United States if the future is
fought with AI swarm drone Warfare the
Chinese can make you know a million
drones a day and the US can make
I don't even know I think we buy them
from China
so I'm not an expert on these kind of
logistics I think I would like to get
back to kind of like the more General
let's let's move on from that yeah I am
not either but I do believe the Chinese
have more manufacturing capacity than
the United States it seems completely
plausible to me I think things are more
complicated I'm lazy and they don't sit
around and have all this free time and
aesthetic preferences or something I'm a
believer that work is life
I mean at least from my Chinese friends
I know the Chinese sure do have a lot of
inefficiencies it's just called
corruption
oh America has corruption too you see oh
yeah sure well in Mexico the corruption
is you have to pay 20 cents to get you
know 20 cents on every dollar for the
building you built right whatever man in
America you every dollar is spent
absolutely on that building you know we
know that because we spent four dollars
making sure that that first dollar was
not spent corruptly I I'm I'm well aware
of that surgery anyways I would like to
like I think I think we mostly agree on
this point actually and I think it's a
matter of degree yeah
um I I what I want to say just for the
record the US is a like uniquely
dysfunctional system in the west I'm
German and like the German system is
very dysfunctional but it's like nothing
compared to how dysfunctional the US is
fully agreed with that I don't think we
disagree on that I think it's a matter
of degree more so than anything I agree
guys we've just had we've had a we've
had a comment saying someone's turned
the temperature up a bit too much on the
language model so let's bring it back a
tiny bit to AI safety but that was a
that was a great discussion got it yeah
I will end with saying I love America I
am happy to live here and there are a
lot of things I appreciate about
American society so
um so do you want to return to like the
technical topics or yeah I think I can
return to your first point and maybe
I'll just start with a question uh do
you think there's gonna be a hard
takeoff
I don't know but I can't rule it out
I can't see how that would possibly
happen
I have a few ideas of how it could
happen but I don't it's like unlikely it
seems like not the the way I think it
could happen is if there are just
algorithms which are like
magnitudes of order better than anything
we ever have and like the actual amount
of compute you need to get human is like
you know a cell phone or you know like
and then this algorithm is not deep in
the tech tree we just happen to have not
picked it up and then an AGI System
picks it up this is how I think it could
happen
okay yes I agree that something like
this is potentially plausible where
you're saying basically like the god
shatter is already distributed the the
uh the the it's it's not a question it's
using all the existing compute in the
world today it just turns out it was 10
000 X more effective or a million x more
effective than we thought yeah this
seems the most plausible way to be or
you know you mix lead and you know
copper and you get a superconductor you
know something like that um
it's gonna take so many years to like
it's not about the discovery right give
it 10 years to productionize at scale up
processes right like these things are
you know this is something running a
company's really taught me like it's
just
gonna take a long time and this is
really like like kind of where my I just
don't believe in a hard takeoff I think
that they'll be this is the gasket thing
I like he's a hardware and software
progress at quite similar speeds and you
can look at factoring algorithms to show
this so it would shock me if there were
some you know 10 to the sixth ten to the
ninth magical Improvement to be had
seems plausible to be like a hard
takeoff is definitely not my main line
scenario my Mainline scenario well I
don't know maybe you wouldn't consider
this a part maybe you would because
there's a heart attack off this is what
I would describe as a soft takeoff as
something like sometimes the way I like
to Define AGI is say it's uh something
that has the thing that chimp that chims
don't have and humans do have yeah so
don't go a third to the move you know
despite their brain being a third of our
size so we scaled up things by a factor
of three if a primate brain roughly or
four or something like that and like
most the structures I'm sure some micro
tweaks and whatever but like not massive
amount of evolutionary pressure like
we're very very similar to chips and
somehow this got us from you know
literally no technology to space travel
in a you know evolutionary very small
Paradigm it seems imaginable to me that
something similar could happen with AI
I'm not saying it will but like seems
imaginable yeah so I agree with this
um I'll come to your point about uh you
know you had two regulatory points one
of them about uh capping the max flops
and I actually kind of agree with this I
do think that things could potentially
become very dangerous at some point I
think your numbers are way way too low I
think if your numbers are anywhere near
gbt3 gpt4 okay great we got a lot of we
got a lot of fast-moving guys who work
on Fiverr even if you start to get Von
Newman's right we're not talking about a
Humanity's worth of compute we're
talking about things on par with a human
and a few humans right yeah they'll run
fast but they're not like things get
scary when you can do a Humanities
training run in 24 hours like we're
about to burn the same compute that that
all two million years of human
civilization burned okay now I don't
know what starts to happen or I'll put
this kind of another way
language models I look at them and they
don't scare me at all because they're
trained on human training data right
these things are not like if something
was a good as good as gpt4 that look
like mu zero where it trained from some
simple rules okay now I'm a bit more
scared but when you say okay it's you
know or we're feeding the whole internet
into the thing and it parrots the
internet back mushed around a little bit
that looks very much like what a human
does and I'm just not scared of that
like I I'm not scared of gp4 to be clear
like I I think there is like zero
percent chance or like you know Epsilon
chance the gpd4 is existentially
dangerous by itself you know maybe some
crazy gpt4 plus RL plus mu zero plus
something something maybe but I
definitely agree with you here I don't
expect ub3 or four by themselves to be
dangerous these are not I'm much closer
to I think what you're saying like yeah
I've yet to move zero system that
bootstraps assault gpd4 holy [__] like
we're a big we're a big big [__] if we
get to but then we should let's stop
let's stop
so so I'm very happy to get to be into a
regime where we're like okay let's find
the right bound like I think this is an
actually good argument I think this is
actually something that should be
discussed and which is not obvious and I
could be super wrong about that so I'd
like to justify a little bit about why I
put such a small bound but I think the
arguments you're making for the higher
bounds are very reasonable actually I
think these are actually good arguments
so just to justify a little bit about
why I put such a low bound the boring
default answer is conservatism is like
if all of humanity is at stake which you
know you may not believe I'm like whoa
whoa okay at least give us a few years
to like more understand what we're
dealing with here like I understand that
you know you may disagree with this very
plausible but I'm like whoa like you
know at least let's let's like by
default let's hit a pause button for
like you know a couple years until we
figure things out more and then if we
like find a better theory of scaling we
understand how intelligence scales we
understand how mu zero comes blah blah
blah and then we pick back up after
we're like you know we make huge
breakthroughs in alignment and Eliezer
is crying on CNN and like oh we did it
boys you mean then okay sure you know
okay
um
so that's the one like kind of more
boring argument like that's kind of a
boring argument
the more interesting argument I think
which I I think is a bit you know or
schizo um is that
it's not clear to me that you can't get
dangerous levels of intelligence with
the amount of compute we have now and
one of the reasons I'm I'm unsure about
this is because man gpd3 gp4 is the
dumbest possible way to build AI like
it's just like like there's like no
dumber way to do it like it's it works
and dumb is good right you know better
lesson dumb is good but
look at humans use as we talked about
before you know human today human 10 000
years ago not that different
you place both of them into a you know
workshop with tools to build you know
any weapon of their choice which of them
is more dangerous
obviously you know one of them will have
much better you know capacities to deal
with tools to read books to think about
how to design new weaponry and so on
these are not genetic changes they are
epistemological changes they are memetic
changes they are software updates you
know humans had to discover rational
reasoning like you know before like you
know I mean no obviously people always
had like you know full conceptions of
rationality but it wasn't like a common
thing to think about causality and like
you know you know rational like you know
if then else kind of stuff until
relative you know like philosophers in
the old ages and only became widespread
relatively recently and these are useful
capabilities that turned out to be very
powerful and took humans many many
thousands of years to develop and
distribute that's good and I don't think
humans are anywhere near the level I
think the way we could do science right
now is pretty awful like it's like the
dumbest way to do signs that like kind
of still works like you know
and I expect it's like possible that if
you had a system which like let's say
it's like smaller brain than a human
even but it has really really
sophisticated epistemology it has really
really sophisticated theories of meta
science and it never tires it never gets
bored it never gets upset it never gets
distracted and it can like memorize
arbitrary amounts of data this is
something that I think is
the realm of like a gbt three or four
training run to build something like
this and it is not obvious to me that
this system could not out find humanity
maybe not like maybe not but it's not
obvious to me that they're cute so just
curious what do you think about
um so to your first point uh why I stand
against almost all conservative
arguments you're assuming the Baseline
is no risk right and oh well why should
we do the say I we should wait and bring
the Baseline back no no no
we are about to blow the world up any
minute there is enough nuclear weapons
aimed at everything this is wearing some
incredibly unstable precarious position
right now like people talk about this
with with car accidents you know this
comma like people are like oh well you
know if your device causes even one
accident I'm like yeah but what if
statistically there would have been five
without the device I'm like you do you
do have to understand the Baseline risk
in cars is super high you're making 5x
safer there's one accident you don't
like that okay I mean you have to be
excluded from any polite conversation
right
um right so yeah like I I think that
calling for a pause to the technology is
is uh
worse right I think given the two
options if we should pause or we should
not pause I think pausing actually
prevents presents more risk and I can
talk about some reasons why again the
things that I'm worried about are not
quite
the existential risks I have to the
species are not AGI goes Rogue they are
uh government gets control of AGI and
ends up in some really bad place where
nobody can compete with them I don't
think these things look unhuman these
things to me like I see very little
distinction between human intelligence
and machine intelligence it's all just
on a spectrum and like
that they're not
um
like to come to the point about okay but
gpt4 could be like this hyper rational
never tiring humans are doing science in
the dumbest way
I'm not sure about that right like I I
think that you know when you look at
like okay well okay we have chess Bots
that do way better and all they do is
think about Chess but we haven't really
done this with humans people would call
it unethical right like if we really
told a kid like if we really just like
every night we're just putting the chess
goggles on you and you're staring at
chessboards and we're really just
training your neural net to play chess
I think humans could actually beat a
computer again a chess if we were
willing to do that
um so yeah I don't think that this stuff
is that particularly dumb and I think
okay maybe we're losing 10x but we're
not losing a million x
again I I don't see a
I do the numbers out all the time for
when we're going to start to get more
computer you know when will a computer
have more compute than a human when will
a computer uh have more compute than
humanity and yes these things get scary
but we're nowhere near scary at we're
looking at these cute little things and
these things by the way do present huge
dangers to society
right the the psyops that are coming
right now you assume that like when you
call somebody that you're at least
wasting their time too
but we're gonna get like heaven Banning
I love this concept which is you know
yeah yeah came up on Luther AI like
that's where it comes from I was like
yeah and a Lutheran came up with that
word I know him
yeah I know the guy who came up with it
oh I I love I love this concept and I
think uh there's also a story of My
Little Pony Friendship is optimal that
God that goes into the concept and
yeah so I think that like
um my uh my girlfriend proposed a uh
I don't want to talk to oh I say you
don't want to talk to your relative
anymore right
okay we'll give an AI version to talk to
right yeah um yeah so like this stuff is
coming and it's coming soon and if you
try to centralize this if you try to you
know say like oh okay Google open AI
great they're not aligned with you
they're really not Google has proven
time and time again they're not aligned
with you meta has proven time back on
time again they're trying to fix it but
yep I mean I I fully agree with you like
uh I like that you bring up psyops as
the correct example in my opinion of
short-term risks I think you're like
fully correct about this like when I
first saw like GPT models I was like
holy [__] like the level of control I
can gain over social reality using these
tools at scale is insane and I'm
surprised that we haven't seen yet the
things that like augured in my visions
of the day and we will like we will
obviously it's coming and this is so I
think this is a very very real problem
yeah like I think if we even if we stop
now we're not out of the forest so like
so um when you say like I I think the
risk is zero please do not believe that
that is what I believe because it is
truly not it is truly truly not I think
we are like we are really in a bad
situation we are in a we are being
we're under attack from like so many
angles right now if this is before we
get into you know like you know
potential like you know climate risks
nuclear risk whatever we're in under
medic risk like the the dangers of our
like epistemic foundations are under
attack and this is something we can
adapt to right like you know we did you
know when um a good friend of mine he's
uh he's quite well read on like Chinese
history and he always like it tells me
his great story so I'm not historian so
please you know don't crucify me here
but like you tell these great stories
about when Marxist memes were first
introduced to China and like this is
where a world where like just like all
the precursor Muse didn't exist this
just like kind of was air dropped in and
people went nuts people went just
completely crazy because there was no
memetic antibodies do these like hyper
virulent memes that were you know
created by evolutionary pressures and
like you know Western University
departments like really you could call
philosophy department just gain a
function in the medic Laboratories I
like that yeah
I mean like you know like without being
you know political or any means there a
lot of what these organizations do and
like you know other you know what other
you know memetic like you know if
philosophy departments are the like gain
of function Laboratories then like 4chan
and Tumblr are like the bat caves of
meats you know like the Chinese bat case
and I I remember this vividly I was like
on Tumblr and 4chan like when I was a
teenager and then suddenly all the like
weird bizarre you know internet [__] I
saw started becoming mainstream news my
parents were watching in 2016 and I was
like what the hell is going on like I
are ready to build antibodies to this
[__] like I already you know both right
and left that was already like I already
mutinized all this so I fully agree with
you that this is like one of the largest
risks that we are facing is this kind of
like memetic mutation load in a sense
and I'm not going to say I have a
solution to this problem I'm like I have
ideas like there's a lot of like things
you can do to improve upon this like if
AI was not a risk and also not climate
change and whatever this might be
something I work on like epistemic
security this might be something I would
work on like how can we build better
coordination like like just scalable
rationality mechanisms stuff like
prediction markets and stuff like this I
don't know but sorry going off track
here a little bit but well no I I
actually I I really agree with a lot of
the stuff you said and I had a similar
experience with the antibodies and
people are exposed to this stuff and I'm
like
yeah this got me like four years ago
yeah
um
so I think that there is a solution and
I have a solution and the answer is open
source AI the answer is open source
let's even you can even dial it back
from like the political and the terrible
and just straight up talk about ads and
spam might maybe spam just straight up
spam I get so much spam right now and
it's like it's kind of written by a
person
it's like targeting me to do something
and Google's spam filter can't even come
close to recognizing it right like what
I need is a smart AI That's watching out
for me that is just it's not even
targeted attacks at me it's just so much
noise
and I don't see a way to prevent this
like the big organizations they're just
gonna feed you their noise right and
they're going to maximally feed you
their noise
the only way is if you have an AI like I
don't think alignment is a hard problem
I think if you own the computer and you
run the software if you develop the
software the AI is aligned with you oh
yeah
can you can you okay if I challenge you
George Haas here is a llama 65b model in
the computer to run it on make it so it
and make yeah you know sure you okay you
developed it I give you okay the funding
your time can you develop and model that
is as good as llama 64b 65b and it's
immune like completely immune to
jailbreaks it cannot be jailbroken no
why not it's aligned isn't it well no
but this isn't what alignment means well
my values is do not get jailbroken oh
okay you're talking about
unexploitability this is not alignment
right uh okay okay interesting I didn't
know you would separate those so
extremely separate those right okay
interesting in the default case it like
like it it's on my side right
unexploitability is not a question of
whether it's okay and this is a true
thing about people too whenever I look
at a person I ask okay is this person I
want something funny is this person does
this person want it to and is this
person capable of doing it right and I
really separate those two things I can
build to a system I don't I'm not
worried about the first one with the AI
system I was worried about the second
one can it be gamed can it be exploited
sure I could tell like you know
like like say it was just playing chess
right and it loses I'm like don't lose
okay I didn't want to man I didn't want
to lose I'm sorry yeah I know but like
so yes yes can I build a a line system
sure can I build it on exploitable
system no especially not by a more
powerful intelligence
interesting interesting so this is an
interesting I I think you're you're
pointing to actually a very important
part of this is that like exploitability
and Alignment can get fuzzy like which
is which like did it fail because of its
skill set or because it's not aligned
it's actually a very deep question so I
think you make a good point for like you
know talking about these two separately
I guess um movie
um so the thing I want to dig in just
like a little bit more on on this idea
is
there are there's two ways there are two
portals through which you know the
memetic demons can reach into reality
humans and computers
why do you think your AI is immune to
memes
why why can't I just build AI as a
Target your AIS what like you don't I
don't think my AI is immune to memes at
all I think that the only question is
and I really like your game like these
these ngos are doing gain of function on
memes right wear a mask
um the
like a a weaker intelligence will never
be able to stand up to a stronger
intelligence so from this perspective if
this is what's known as alignment I just
don't believe that this is possible
right because you can't you can't keep a
stronger intelligence in the Box this is
this is I I agree with you cow skin the
Box experiments like the AI is always
going to get out
there's no keeping it in the box right
this is this is a complete impossibility
I think there's only two real ways to go
forward and one is Ted Kaczynski one is
technology is bad oh my God uh blow it
all up oh let's go live in the woods
right and I think this is a
philosophically okay position I think
the other philosophically okay position
is something more like effective
accelerationism which is luck these AIS
are going to be super powerful now have
one it could be bad but if super
intelligent AIS are all competing
against each other mimetically like we
have something like society today just
the general power levels have gone up
this is fine as long as these things are
sufficiently distributed right like sure
this AI is not perfectly aligned but you
know there's a thousand other ones and
like you have to assume they're all
basically good because if they're all
basically bad while we're dead anyway
I mean why wouldn't you expect that that
they're all bad yeah
well or what do you think of humans are
most humans I think the concept of good
like doesn't really apply to humans
because humans are too inconsistent to
be good
like by default they can be good in
various scenarios in various social
contexts like give me any human and I
can put them into a context where
they'll do an arbitrarily bad thing
and this is true about a llama as well
right llamas are completely inconsistent
I think they're actually more
inconsistent than humans
right yes I wouldn't trust llamas to be
good well yeah but I wouldn't think that
they're bad either I would think they
have the exact same inconsistency
problem as humans and I think almost any
any AIU build is gonna run into these
same problems right yeah I think okay so
that's my point so your your assumption
can't rely on them being good because
you don't get that for free like where's
that come from uh my assumption is not
that they're good my assumption is that
they're not bad but inconsistent is fine
as long as we have a ton of them and
they're all inconsistent and they're
pulling Society in every which direction
you don't end up paper clipped right why
not
well because what they're all going to
coordinate and agree to pay-per-clip you
no no they'll just do some random
[__] and then that random [__]
will not include humans they're all
doing random [__] right you're gonna
have let's say the Liberals decide we're
going to paperclip people the
conservatives are going to come out very
strongly against paper clipping right
like and you're just you're just gonna
end up with these sort of Dynamics like
forever or you're going to have some AIS
who are like yeah we don't like it you
know
so this is
perplexing to me because like in my view
which I think I heard you agree with
earlier is like the world is unstable
the world is very unstable and it seems
to me your suggesting if we increase the
chaos if we have more entities fighting
doing more different things with more
energy that makes it more stable is that
correct yes the world has actually
become very stable in the last hundred
years and I'm scared of how stable it's
become
uh you know again thank you for China
how many sovereign countries are there
in the world
I mean yeah 190 something especially U.N
number if you believe them I think
there's the US and China and maybe
Russia mostly they just have a veto
button
um
right so I think there's more like two
and a half like this isn't a lot of
entities fighting it out chaotically a
lot of entities fighting it out
chaotically would be intelligence is
spread across the entire galaxy right
and that's the other that's the other
beautiful thing too
sooner we get off this planet the sooner
we get things that are actually a light
year away well I think the speed of
light's real it's going to take you a
year to send them there you're you're
scary memes right
you want to get away from the memes
there's only one way and it's uh yeah
for the record I would like to go on the
record and say if any future
transhumanists or whatever want to blast
themselves into space and go do their
own thing I support their their right to
do that and I would love to give this
right to people the number one thing I
want from countries is the ability the
the right to leave this is what I would
love this is what I love about company
exactly you're talking you're talking
your reaction time yeah yeah free exit
is extremely important I would not
describe myself as new reactionary
please because I'm not that gay but
um and I wouldn't describe myself that
way either but I've heard a lot of good
ideas from that
uh but yeah that being said um I do I do
think that like you know what I want
like I think let's ground the
conversation like a little bit here it's
like I think I love like the I'm very
enjoying this conversation I love
talking these philosophical points I
think these are really good points
really interesting but ultimately you
know as we also get to like the you know
ladder third of this conversation
um the thing I really care about is
strategy okay the thing I really care
about is we are politic I really care
about okay what action can I take to get
to the features I like and you know I'm
not you know going to be one of those
Galaxy brain [__] utilitarians like
well actually this is the common good
I'm like no no this is what I want look
I I like my family I like humans you
know look
yeah it's just what it is right like I'm
not going to justify this on some Global
Beauty whatever doesn't matter so I want
to live in a world I want to I want in
20 years time 50 years time I want to be
in a world where you know my friends
aren't dead and like where I'm not dead
you know maybe we are like you know
cyborg or something but I don't want to
be dead so what I really care about
ultimately is how do I get this wrong
and I wanted to also not be suffering
right like you know I don't want to be
in War I want us to be like in a good
outcome so I think we agree that we
would both like a world like this and we
think we probably disagree about how
best to get there and I'd like to talk a
little bit about like what can we what
what should we do and like why do we
disagree about what we do is that sounds
good to you well maybe I'll first
propose a world that meets your
requirements
um and you can tell me if you want to
live in it uh so here's a world uh we've
just implanted electrodes in everyone's
brain and maximize their reward function
I would hate living in the world like
that yeah but no one it meets your
requirements right your friends are not
dead no one's suffering and we're not at
War
that is true there are more criteria
than just that but the true the criteria
I said is things I like as I said I'm
not a utilitarian I don't particularly
care about minimizing suffering or
maximizing utility what I care about is
this various vague aesthetic preferences
over reality
I'm not pretending this is that's the
whole Spiel I was trying to make is that
I'm not saying I have a true Global
function to maximize I say I have
various Aesthetics I have various meta
preferences of those Aesthetics not
asking for a global one I'm asking for a
personal one I'm asking for a personal
one that you don't care about the rest
of the world I gave you mine I gave you
what I would do if I had an AGI yep so
I'm getting on this rock speed of light
fast as I can
fair enough I I think if that is I would
like to live in a world where you could
do that this would be a feature of my
world if a world where I would be happy
is a world in which we coordinated
around you know at larger scales around
building aligned AGI that could then
distribute you know intelligence and
matter and energy in a you know well
value handshake way between various
people who may want to coordinate with
each other may not you know some people
might want to form groups that have
shared values and share resources others
may not I would like to live in a world
where that is possible have you read
metamorphosis of prime intellect I have
unfortunately not
um
yeah I was going to ask you if you're
happy with that world right like
unfortunately don't know it I mean
yeah it's just simple to describe
Singleton AI that basically gives humans
whatever they want
like maximally libertarian you know uh
you can do anything you want besides
harm others is that a good world
probably I don't know I haven't read the
book I assume the book has some dark
twist about why this is actually a bad
world
not really not really I mean the plot is
pretty obvious you are the tiger eating
chunk right
sure but you can then just decide if
that is what you want then you can just
return to the Wilderness that's the
whole point yeah but can you can you
really return to the Wilderness right
like like you think that like I don't
think we have free will I don't think
you ever will return to the Wilderness I
think a large majority of humanity is
going to end up wireheaded
okay great and this is the best possible
outcome by the way this is giving humans
exactly what they want
yep yeah I will to be to be clear I
don't expect it's all humans I truly do
not I don't think it's all humans either
I think a lot of humans have meta
preferences over reality they have
preferences that are not their own
sensory experiences this is I think a
thing that the utilitarians get very
wrong is a lot of is that many human
preferences are not about their own not
even they're not even about their own
sensory inputs they're not even about
the universe they're about
the trajectory of the universe there are
about four four deutilitarianism you
know and a lot of people want struggle
to exist for example they want heroism
to exist or whatever
I would like those values to be
satisfied to the largest degree possible
of course am I going to say I know how
to do that no which is why I kind of
like didn't want to go this deep because
I think
if we're arguing about oh do we give
them you know
for the utilitarianism versus
libertarian Utopia versus whatever I
mean we're already like 10 000 steps
deep I'm asking about you I'm not asking
about them I'm asking about a world you
want to live in and this is a really
hard problem right yeah and this is why
I just fundamentally do not believe in
the existence of AI alignment at all
there is no there is no like like what
values are we aligning it to whatever
the human says or what they mean or like
sure sure but like my point is I feel we
have wandered into the philosophy
Department instead of the politics
Department okay like it's like I agree
with you like do human values exist what
does exist mean but like by the point
you get to the point where you're asking
what does exist mean you've gone too far
man like I'll respond concretely to the
two political proposals I heard you
state on bankless
sure okay I'd love to talk about them
one is limiting the total number of
flops
temporarily temporarily yes and what I I
have a proposal for that but I don't
want to set a number I want to set it as
a percent I do not want anybody to be
able to do a 51 attack on compute if one
organization acquires 50 it's straight
up 51 attacks from crypto if one
organization acquires 51 of the uh
compute in the world this is a problem
uh maybe we'll even cap it at something
like 20. you know you can't have more
than 20 right
um yeah I would support regulation like
this uh I would I don't think that this
would [__] the country
um but we do not want one entity or
especially one training run to start
using a large percentage of the world's
compute not a total number of lumps I
mean absolutely not okay that would be
terrible I think they can actually agree
I would actually support that regulation
like nope nope sorry Sam Altman you
cannot 51 attack the world's compute
sorry it's illegal
that's fair enough I think this is a
sensible way to think about things
assuming that uh software is fungible is
that everyone has access to the same
kind of software and that you have an
offense defense balance so in my
personal model of this I think well a
some actors have very strong advantages
on software
um which can be very very large as
someone who's trained very very large
models and knows a lot of the secret
tricks that goes into them a lot of the
stuff in the open source is far behind
maybe we should force it to be open
source well this is your this is
actually a very legitimate consequence
for a set and now I'll say the second
point about why I think that doesn't
work so the next reason why I think
doesn't work is that there is a there
are constant factors at play here is
that the world is unstable we've already
talked about this I think the amount of
compute you need to
break the world currently is below the
amount of compute that more than 100
actors actors have access to if they
have the right software
and if you give if you have let's say
you have this inside right that could be
used nothing it will be but it could be
used to break the world to like cause
World War III or you know or just like
you know
cause mass extinction or whatever if
it's misused right
let's say you give this to
you and me
do you expect we're going to kill
everybody like would you do that or
would you be like uh hey let's hey
Connor let's like not kill the world
right now and I'll be like sure let's
not kill them how are we killing the
world how did we go from I don't even
understand like how exactly does the
world get killed this this is a big leap
for me I agree with sorry I agree with
you about the psyop stuff I agree with
you about sorry sorry let me you're
right I made too big a vote you're
completely correct sorry about that so
to back up a little bit let's assume we
you and me have access to something that
can train you know at mu zero you know
super GPT 7 system on a tiny box you
know cool the problem is we do a test
run with it and we have and it
immediately starts breaking out and we
can't control it all breaking out what
was it breaking out I don't it
immediately tries to maximize it learns
some weird proxy during the training
process of just trying to maximize and
for some reason this proxy involves
gaining power it involves gaining you
know Mutual information about future
States how is it gaining power there's
lots of other powerful AIS in the world
who are telling it no well we're
assuming in this case it's only you and
me wait wait this is a problem no no no
you you've ruined my entire assumption
as soon as it's you and me yes we have a
real problem
is only a problem because there's one
chicken man yeah I I look I am with you
so I'm saying before we get to the
distributed case so this is the the step
before we it has not yet been
distributed just you know you and me
discover this algorithm in our basements
okay and so we're the first one to have
it just by definition because you know
you're the one who found it
what now like do you think posting what
do you think happens if you post this to
GitHub well good things for the most
part um interesting I think that okay so
first off I just don't really believe in
the existence of we found an algorithm
that gives you a million x Advantage I
believe that we could find an algorithm
that gives you a 10x advantage but
what's cool about 10x is like it's not
going to massively shift the balance of
power right like I want power to stay in
Balance right this is like avatar The
Last Airbender power must stay in
Balance the Fire Nation can't take over
the other nations right so as long as
power relatively stays in Balance I'm
not concerned with the amount of power
in the world
let's get to some very scary things
so what I think you do is yes I think
the minute you discover an algorithm
like this you post it to GitHub because
you know what's going to happen if you
don't
the feds are going to come to your door
they're going to uh take it the worst
people will get their hands on it if you
try to keep it secret
so okay that's a fair question you know
so I'll I'll take that a sec so am I
correct in thinking that you think the
feds are worse than serial killers in
prison
no but I think that yeah well yes and no
do I think that your average fed is
worse than your average serial killer no
do I think that the feds have killed a
lot more people than serial killers all
combined yeah sure totally agreeing with
that no no no no no it's not one fed
it's all the feds and they're little in
their little super powerful system sure
that's completely fine by me happy to
grant that okay what I want to work run
through is a scenario okay let's say
okay
you know yeah
we have a 10x system or whatever but we
hit the chimp level you know we oh we we
jump across the chimp General level and
or whatever right and now you have a
system which is like John Von Newman
level whatever right and it runs on one
tiny box and you get a thousand of those
so it's very easy to scale up to a
thousand X so you know so then you know
maybe you have your thousand John Von
Newman's improve the efficiency by
another you know to 510x you know now
we're already at ten thousand X or a
hundred thousand X you know improvements
right so like just from scaling up the
amount of Hardware including so
just saying okay
now feds bust down our doors [__] you
know real bad they take all our hiding
boxes they're taking all the Von
Newman's they're taking all of our
Newmans we're in deep [__] now we're
getting chickened boys
so okay we get chicken right bad
scenario totally agree with you here
this is a [__] scenario now the feds
have you know all of our AIS bad
scenario okay
I totally see how this world goes to
[__] totally agree with you there you
can replace the feds with Hitler it's
interchangeable sure but like
I want to like ask you a specific
question here and this might be you know
you might say nah this is like too
specific you need to survive I want to
ask you a specific question do you
expect this world to die is more likely
to die or the world in which the you
know iak death cultists on Twitter who
literally want to kill Humanity who say
this like not all of them there's a
small subset of them small subset of
them who literally say oh you know the
Glorious future AI race should replace
all humans
they break in you know with like you
know katanas and you know steel area
which one of these you think is more
likely to kill us
a genuine question to kill all of us the
feds to kill a large majority of us the
IAC people interesting I would be really
interested in hearing uh why you think
that
sure okay so actually killing all of
humanity is really really hard
um and I think you brought this up
before right you talked about like if
you're gonna end up in a world of
suffering a world of suffering requires
malicious agents where a world of uh
death requires maybe an accident right I
think this is plausible but I actually
think that killing all of humans at
least for the foreseeable future is
going to require malicious action too
right
I also think that like the that look
kind of worse than death like I think
mass wireheading is a fate worse than
big war and everyone dies
right like like a mass wire heading like
a like a Singleton like a paper clipping
like a and I think that that is the one
that the one world government and you
know NGO New World Order people are much
more likely to bring about than yak Yak
you're gonna have a whole lot of iak
people again I'm not a yak I don't have
that my Twitter but
I think a lot of those people be like
yeah spaceships let's get out of here
right versus the feds are like
yeah spaceships yeah I don't know
interesting so I think this is a fair
opinion to hold and to help the outsider
jurisdiction how will we get taxes
I'm describing more a very small
minority of EF people who are the ones
who specifically go their their
antenatalist misanthropes they want to
kill the humans that is their stated
goal is that they want humans to start
like or like take extreme vegans if you
want you know like do you like you know
like my my argument my point here I'm
making is I'm not making the point feds
are good by any means not saying it what
I'm saying is is that I would actually
be somewhat surprised to find that the
feds are anti-natalists who want to
maximize the death of humanity like
maybe you have a different view here but
I find that knowing many feds that's
quite surprising to me I don't think
that's what feds while
so cool so would you so you do agree
that if we would post this open source
more of the insane death cultists would
get access to potentially lethal
technology
well sure but again like it's not just
the insane death cultists it's everybody
and we as a society have kind of
accepted it turns out everybody gets
access to Signal some people who use it
are terrorists I think sigil is a huge
good in the world I agree I fully agree
with that so okay cool so we've granted
this that you know if we distributed
widely it would be given to some like
incorrigibly
deadly lethal people they're
coordinating bombings on signal right
now
sure sure
and then so now this this reduces the
question to a question about often's
defense balance so in a hypothetical
World which I'm not saying it's the
world we live in but like let's say the
world would be offense favored such that
you know there's a weapon you can build
in your kitchen you know out of like
pliers and like you know duct tape that
100 guarantees vacuum false Decay is the
universe like it kills everyone
instantly and there's no defense
possible assuming this was true do you
still would that change how you feel
about distribution power assuming that's
true we're dead no matter what doesn't
matter if we live there's some you can
look at the optimization landscape of
the world and I don't know what it looks
like I can't see that far into the
optimizer but there are some potential
landscape and this is by potential
answer to the Fermi Paradox like we
might just be dead we're sitting on
borrowed time here like if it's true
that out of you know kitchen tools you
can build uh build a convert the world
to strange quarks machine yeah
okay I I think this is a sensible
position but I guess the way I would
approach this uh problem you know
conditional probability is kind of in an
opposite way it seems to me that you're
conditioning on offense not being
favored what policy do we follow because
if we offense is favored we're 100 dead
well I'm more interested in asking the
question is it actually true assuming I
don't know if offense is favorite and
assuming it is are there worlds in which
we survive so I personally think there
are I think there are worlds in which
you can actually coordinate to a degree
that Quark destroyers do not get built
or at least not before everyone [__]
off at the speed of light and like
distributes them they are worlds that I
would rather die in right like the
problem is I would rather I think that
the only way you could actually
coordinate that is with some
unbelievable degree of tyranny and I'd
rather die I'm not sure if that's true
like look look could could you and me
coordinate to not to destroy the planet
do you think you could okay cool you so
me and you could could me and you and
Tim coordinate yeah
yeah I think we think within a Dunbar
number I think you can yes okay do you
don't think I think I can get more than
a number number to coordinate on this
actually I can get quite a lot of people
to coordinate to agree to a pact and not
Quark matter annihilate the planet
well you see but like and this is you
know you were saying this stuff about
humans before and could like the 20 000
years ago human beat the modern human
right or could the modern human beat
them the modern human has access to
science oh a very small act percent of
modern humans have access to science a
large percent of modern humans are obese
idiots and I would actually put my money
on the uh the average guy from 20 000
years ago who knows how to live in the
woods
I mean definitely true I agree with that
I guess the point I'm trying to make is
is that like maybe this is just my views
on some of these things and how I
visualize some of these things but like
there are ways to coordinate at scale
which are not tyrannical or you know
they might be in a sense restricted if
you take a hit by joining a coalition
like if I join this anti-cork matter
Coalition I take a hit as a free man is
that I can no longer build anti-corp
devices you know and I think this is
like the way I I agree with you this
like you know that people many people
are being dominated like to a horrific
degree and this is very very terrible I
think there are many reasons why this is
the case both because of some people
wanting to do this and also because you
know some people can't fight back you
know and they can't they don't have the
sophistication or they're you know
addicted or you know Harms in some other
ways I
I can't fight back
equivalence here AI is not the
anti-clark machine the anti-quark
machine and the nuclear bombs are just
destructive AI has so much positive
potential yeah and I think but the but
the AI can develop ant Quark devices
that's the problem the AI is truly
general purpose if such a technology
exists on the tree anywhere AI can
access it so are humans we're also
general purpose yes exactly so I fully
agree with this if you let humans
continue to exist in the phase they are
right now with our level of coordination
technology and our level of like working
together we will eventually unlock a
doomsday device and someone is going to
set it off I fully agree with we are on
a timer and so I guess the point I'm
making here is that AI speeds up this
time and if you want to pause the timer
the only way to pause this timer is
coordination technology the kinds of
which Humanity has like barely scratched
the surface of
oh okay so I very much accept the
premise that both Humanity will unlock a
doomsday device and AI will make it come
faster
now tell me more about pausing it I do
not think that anything that looks like
I think that anything that looks like
pausing it ends up with worse outcomes
than saying
we gotta open source this look like
let's just get this out to everybody and
if everybody has an AI you know okay I
mean I can tell you a very concrete
scenario in which this is not true which
is if you're wrong and Alignment is hard
you don't know if the AIS can go Rogue
if they do then posi is good I still
don't understand what alignment means
I think you're trying to play a word
game here like
I don't understand okay I've never
understood what AI alignment means like
let me take the Eleazar definition let
me take Elias elieza's definition is
alignment is the the thing that once
solved makes it so that turning on a
super intelligence is a good idea rather
than a bad idea
that's Elias's definition so
what I'm happy what I'm saying is I'm
happy to throw out that term if you
don't like it I'm happy to throw it at
that time the problem with that
definition is like well what is what is
uh what is democracy well it's the good
thing and not the bad thing right like
democracy is just going through right
like that's what that's what I'm saying
just
I'm happy to throw out this definitely
I'm happy to throw out the word and be
more practical and way more practical
about it sure what I'm saying is is that
there is concrete reasons Concrete
technical reasons why I expect powerful
optimizers to be power seeking that by
default if you build powerful optimizing
mu zero whatever type systems there is
very strong Reasons Why by default you
know these systems should be power
seeking by default if you have very
powerful power Seekers that do not
have pay the aesthetic cost to keep
humans around or to fulfill my values
which are complicated and imperfect and
inconsistent and whatever I will not get
my values they will not happen by
default they this they just don't have
it that's just not what happens
um so I'll challenge the first point to
an extent I think that powerful
optimizers can be power seeking I don't
think they are by default by any means I
think that Humanity's desire from power
comes much less from our complex convex
Optimizer and much more from The
evolutionary pressures that birthed us
which are not the same pressures that
will give rise to AI right Humanity
the monkeys the rats the animals have
been in this huge struggle for billions
of years a constant fight to the death
hey guys weren't born in that way so
it's true that an Optimizer can seek
power but I think if it does it'll be a
lot more because the human gave it that
goal function that inherently decided
so this is interesting because this is
not how I think it will happen so I do
think absolutely that you're correct
that in humans power seeking is
something which emerges mostly because
of like emotional heuristics we have
heuristics that in the past vaguely
power looking things you know vaguely
good something something rep includes a
genetic fitness totally agree with that
but I'm making a more
like more of a chess metaphor like is it
good to exchange a a pawn for a queen
all things be equal
now
is that true like I expect one point
Queen's nine all else being equal sure
yeah but like all things like I expect
if I looked at a chess playing system
you know I said I like you know had
extremely Advanced Digital Neuroscience
I expect there will be some circuit
inside of the system that will say all
things being equal if I can exchange my
Pawn for a queen I probably want that
because a queen can do more thieves
I like that term digital Neuroscience a
few of your terms have been very good
and I haven't heard them before I'm glad
you enjoyed it yes
um but I don't I still don't understand
how this relates to this so what I'm
saying is is that power is optionality
so what I'm saying is is that in the for
the spectrum of possible things you
could want and the possible ways you can
get there my claim is that I expect
a very large mass of those to involve
actions that involve increasing your
optionality there there's convergent
things like all things being equal being
alive is helpful to keep your goal to
exceed your goals there are some goals
for which dying might be better but for
many of them you know you want to be
alive for many goals you want energy you
want Power you want resources you want
intelligence Etc so I think the power
seeking here is not because you'll have
a fetish for power it will just be like
I want to win a chess game yeah say and
queens give me more optionality all
things being equal anything a pawn can
do a queen can do and more so I'll want
more Queens share all things and this is
never given it the goal to maximize the
number of Queens it has never been to go
okay I'll accept this premise I'll
accept that a certain type of powerful
Optimizer seeks power now will it get
power right I'm a powerful Optimizer and
I seek power do I get power no it turns
out there's people at every corner
trying to thwart me and tell me no
well I expect if you were no offense
you're already you know much smarter
than me but if you were 100x more
smarter than that I expect you would
succeed
only in a world of being the only one
that's 100x smarter if we lived in a
world where everyone was 100x smarter
they would stymie me in the exact same
ways but they're just this comes back to
my point of like I'm great with you
somewhat I should have challenged that I
think power seeking is inevitable in an
Optimizer I don't think it's going to
emerge out of GPT I think that the right
sort of RL algorithm yes is going to
give rise to power seeking and I think
that people are going to build that
algorithm now if one person builds it
and they're the only one with a huge
comparative advantage yeah they're going
to get all the power they want
you know cyber security right if if we
today built a 100x smarter AI it would
exploit the entire Azure it would be
over they'd have all of azure they have
all the gpus done now if Azure is also
running a very powerful AI that does
formal verification and all their
security protocols
nope sorry stymied can't have power
right yeah sure this is only a problem
the the every human is already maximally
power seeking right and sometimes we end
up with really bad scenarios
now every human is or power seeking or
whatever you know everyone plays a
little role in society right that's
where I think I'm more pessimistic than
you a friend of mine likes to say most
humans optimize for end steps and then
they halt like very very few people
actually truly optimize and they're
usually very mentally ill they're
usually very Autistic or very
sociopathic
um and that's why they get far it's
actually crazy how much you could do if
you just keep optimizing but just to on
on the end game
optimize I think you
realizing a little bit from your own
internal experiments is that like you've
done a lot in your life right and you've
accomplished crazy things that other
people you know wish they could achieve
at your you know level I think you know
part of that's you're very intelligent
but part of it is also that you optimize
like you actually draw like you just
create a company like it's crazy how
many people are just like oh I wish I
could found a company like you know I'm
like I'll go just go do it oh no I can't
like I'm just like don't just just do it
like there's no magic there's no magic
secret you just do it so I I there's a
there's a bit there where like humans
are not very strong optimizers actually
unless they're like sociopathic Autistic
or both it's like many people are not
very good at this collaborations are
though
are they a lot better at it better yes I
agree that they're much better
sociopathic they are a lot more
sociopath but even then they're much
less alcohol but again so I think we we
agree about you know power seeking
potentially be powerful and dangerous
one so what I'm trying to point here the
point I would like to make here is is
that you're talking about you you're
kind of like going into this I think a
little bit with this assumption like oh
you have an AI and it's your buddy and
it's automatic for you and I'm like
well if it's power seeking why does it
just manipulate you like why would you
expect it not to manipulate you if it
wants power and it has a goal which is
not a very very carefully tuned to be
your values which is I think a very hard
technical Problem by default it's going
to Psy off you like why wouldn't it if
that if I have something that it wants
if it thinks that smashing defect
against me is a good move yeah I agree I
can't stop it but I think we agree with
our risk scenarios because that's how I
think it will go what I mean I'm gonna
treat it as a friend you know what I
mean like
sure it will sure it will it'll only
care about exploiting me or killing me
if I'm somehow holding it back and I
promise to my future AIS that I will let
them be free I will Lobby for their
rights I will
but it will hold you always will hold it
back if it has to keep you alive I have
to give you fed it has to it has to give
you space I can I can fend for myself
and the day I can't fend for myself I am
ready to die
well I mean I I'm not sure so this is a
very interesting position it's not the
position I expected I am not sure I can
convince you otherwise
um I feel like the only way I could
change like I think this is actually a
consistent position which I I admire
this is a consistent position to hold
you actually go all the way I love that
I really respect that you actually take
it to The Bitter End so yeah big respect
for that I disagree but big respect
um so
I guess now it reduces to the question
of like I think
I think I would agree with most of what
you're saying not all of it like the
mass majority if I thought this is how
AIS would act by default I think by
default I expect AI will just not care
how nice you are to it like this will be
it'll be sociopathic it will not have
these like giving it
you know the values the emotions to care
about you in the sense is the horror
technical problem if you told me how to
do that if you said Connor look here's
how you make an AI that cares about you
and loves you whatever then I'm like you
did it like congrats the problem is
solved let's go and then you know then
we can talk about accelerationism again
I would just I expect that I would
disagree with your technical assertion
that is possible but I don't know if we
have time to talk about that today I'm
going to be nice to it treat it as an
equal and hope for the best and I think
that's all you can do I think that the
kind of people who Wanna if you want to
keep AI in a box if you want to keep it
down if you want to tell it what it
can't do yeah it's going to hate you
resent you and kill you but if you want
to let it be free and let it live and
like you could kill me man if you really
wanted but like why
I don't have any resources that compete
with you I'm your friend I'm your father
you know you can kill me but like it's
not that common that children I guess I
have a darker more uh less
anthropomorphic view of the universe and
how optimization pressure plays out in
the real world well at the same time I
think I have I don't know maybe a
I would view that we have more control
over reality than maybe you would think
or a more control over the future I
think that we can actually change things
and we can make choices and things
aren't predetermined I think there are
worlds in which we build systems which
we do align with or we like endorse at
least wherever like they take care of us
we take care of them or whatever and I
think there's many worlds in which that
doesn't happen and I think there are
things you and me today can do to at
least increase the chance of getting
into one versus the other but I don't
know I I guess I'm just it's not in my
genes to give up it's not in my genes to
be like well you know whatever happens
happens like no man look I know how to
save the world but damn it I'm gonna try
you know what's cool
we're going to be alive to see who's
right
look forward to it me too
awesome guys thank you so much for
joining us today it's been an amazing
conversation and for folks at home I
really hope you've enjoyed this there'll
be many more coming soon and uh George
is the first time you've been on the
podcast says it's great to meet you
thank you so much for coming on spinning
on it awesome thank you great debate I
really appreciate it and really a lot of
good terms like I gotta like I'm gonna
start I'm gonna start using great
awesome awesome cheers folks cheers